traduction simultanée
première question l'association des
correspondants de lune je vous donne la
parole
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
conférence de presse
je m'appelle var et valérie robic à ma
question porte sur l'afghanistan
quelles possibilités et quels facteurs
de risque existe-t-il
dans ce mouvement des talibans en
afghanistan la russie at elle peur que
la présence des palais des talibans
puissent
favoriser
l'islamisme dans la région ou à votre
avis les talibans se ralentir merci
beaucoup l'afghanistan est évidemment
dans l'esprit de tous et nous partons du
principe que d'être depuis le début ce
qui s'est passé est une réalité
malheureusement
le départ précipité appelons le comme ça
d
troupes américaines et d'autres pays de
l'otan
sans réflexion sur les conséquences et
les conséquences vous les connaissez
c'est que aujourd'hui en afghanistan un
armement en quantité considérable et
reste et nous avons besoin de faire en
sorte que cet armement ne soient pas
utilisés dans des buts qui ne sont pas
constructifs et la réalité qui existe
sur place
repose sur les déclarations des talibans
qui ont proclamé donc leur résolution de
lutter contre l'extrémisme
contre l'extrémisme
de l'état islamique et d'autres
groupements ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
respecter les droits des femmes qu'ils
allaient créer un gouvernement
inclusif vous savez tout ça très bien et
l'important c'est que ces promesses wasp
était la première étape c'est la mise en
place d'une structure gouvernementale de
transition qui en fait ne reflète pas
l'ensemble de la variété de la diversité
culturelle et confessionnelle de
l'afghanistan et on voit que ces luttes
se poursuivre il ya des discussions de
plusieurs années qui se poursuivent dans
la truck a élargi et
notamment mais des représentants russes
chinois pakistanais qui se sont
rencontrés à doha à istanbul et avec des
représentants des du pouvoir civil
laïque je pense à ramer travail et à
droite de la com représentants
de la société civile et je pense que
c'est important que nous puissions avoir
une structure gouvernementale qui puisse
être représentative les talibans disent
qu'ils sont sur cette voie et que sais
tu que n'est qu'une question de temps
mais encore une fois l'essentiel c'est
obtenir que les promesses qu'ils ont
faites publiquement qu'elle soit
respecter et honorer et c'est la
priorité que vous avez évoqué vous même
c'est
la non prolifération de l'extrémisme
notamment dans les pays voisins et la
limitation de la menace terroriste sur
le territoire de l'afghanistan donc ils
ont dit qu'ils allaient se battre avec
contre l'état islamique et les autres
mouvements terroristes et nous espérons
que cela va se concrétiser
bonjour interfax monsieur lavrov une
autre question sur l'afghanistan la
russie considère tel s possibilité
d'abolir l'origine des sanctions à
l'égard des talibans qui font partie du
nouveau gouvernement de l'afghanistan
pour faciliter des contacts avec eux et
quelle position à la russie va-t-elle
adopté dans le cadre des discussions
dans le lieu concernant les sanctions à
l'égard des talibans
vous savez la situation actuelle
n'empêche pas nos contacts avec les
talibans comme je les dis de plus les
sanctions du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu l'interdît pas nathalie spa des
contacts
[Musique]
et c'est ce qu'a dit le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu c'est qu'il faut
travailler avec les talibans et les
contacts que nous avons depuis plusieurs
années comme je le dis avec ce mouvement
vise avant tout à assurer la sécurité
des citoyens russes et deuxièmement de
contribuer au dialogue inter afghans
je n'ai pas entendu dire que
conseil de sécurité et
aborder ces questions dans les
discussions qui va y avoir
encore une fois je dis que l'objectif
dans la situation actuelle et du travail
que nous faisons actuellement
est clair et je pense que tout le monde
le comprend et comme j'ai dis dans ma
réponse précédente nous attendons que
les talibans remplissent les promesses
qu'ils ont faites et nous allons
regarder à quel point la menace
narcotiques la menace terroriste
disparaissent du territoire de
l'afghanistan
merci
space el jazeera encore des questions
sur la liste 1 le secrétaire général
parle des conséquences catastrophiques
du
collapse
économique que pensez-vous de l'ailé du
dégel des fonds afghans qui sont entre
les mains des organisations
internationales
deuxième question je vous parlais du
vous dites qu'il faut juger l'été les
bains selon leur activité et l'idiot
l'idéologie des talibans est elle
différente des dangers islamistes en
syrie par exemple en syrie comme vous le
savez se trouve un nid terroriste reste
que l'ensemble du territoire syrien a
été libéré mais dans la zone dite de
d'escaladé à idleb et est le groupe et
de rachat qui en fait la bataille nous
sera et qui a été identifié dans toutes
les décisions du conseil de sécurité
comme organisation terroriste et en
conséquent ici je ne vois pas ici
de problème vis-à-vis de l'élimination
des terroristes en syrie nous
travaillons vrai que nos collègues
turquie il ya deux ans ont conclu un
accord spécial avec nous en disant
qu'ils allaient lutter contre les
terroristes dans la zone de désescalade
idleb et
séparer les groupes armés qui ne sont
pas terroristes et qui coopère avec les
militaires turcs
dans quelques jours nous aurons une
nouvelle rencontre entre les présidents
turc et russe et justement à l'ordre du
jour il leur à cette question c'est à
dire
la mise en pratique concrète qui est
très lente de cette décision les
talibans par rapport à d'autres groupes
encore une fois
on ne peut pas diviser les terroristes
en bons et mauvais mais les sanctions
qui ont été introduites contre les
talibans
justement était
formulée de façon à ce qu'on puisse
discuter avec et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas ne pas les
considérer comme on ne peut pas les ne
pas les considérer comme des
interlocuteurs non valable donc
aujourd'hui c'est là qu'est la
différence donc effectivement nous
allons
encourager ceux qui ont pris le pouvoir
à kaboul après la fuite du contingent
étranger à à prendre leurs
responsabilités
oui nous avons parlé de ça et nous
considérons que cette question doit être
examinée justement sur la base des
positions que vous avez cités en citant
le secrétaire général de l'onu
a choisi son candidat pour le poste de
l'ambassadeur à moscou la russie sur un
tel prêt à donner l'agrément aux
personnes
choisi par le moment
nous n'avons pas d'informations sur le
fait d'avoir
une demande d'agrément
le
l'ambassadeur précédent est en poste
aujourd'hui personne ne pose la question
de la légitimité des talibans et nous
partons du principe que si à un moment
nous de nous
deux recevons une demande d'agrément
pour un nouvel ambassadeur à ce moment
là on verra
nous avons entendu le discours de joe
biden il a proclamé que l'époque des
bières était finie et qu'elle était
remplacé par l'époque du diplomatie
offensif y croyez-vous et deuxième
question c'est la propriété diplomatique
et le sujet des visas pour aller membres
de la délégation parce que notre
délégation aurait pu ne pas être venue à
cause
des exigences sur la vaccination
qu'en pensez vous je pense pas que ce
soit une tentative de faire du tort mais
je pense que c'est simplement une
situation de désarroi dans la mesure où
on a une reprise des rencontres en
présentiel ici donc je peux pas accuser
les les autorités de new york de prendre
de telles mesures simplement ils ont
peut-être peur de
risque les variants
ne cessent de se multiplier donc on
comprend qu'il ya des menaces mais vous
avez raison vous l'avez dit
nous sommes contre toutes les tentatives
de discrimination l'égard des vaccins
qui ne sont pas enregistrés aux états
unis mais qui ont prouvé leur efficacité
dans d'autres pays contre le coc vide il
ya un certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne par exemple la hongrie la
slovaquie qui ont adopté le vaccin sans
doute négligé et donc
ce sont des pays qui sont membres de
l'alliance atlantique qui alors après
sur les visas pour le personnel
diplomatique
il ya des considérations épidémiologique
ici mais il ya aussi un retard politique
un certain nombre de notre personnel
diplomatique n'a pas reçu sedima et
notamment des membres de la douma qui
n'ont pas pu qui font partie de la
délégation qui n'ont pas pu venir donc
donc nous avons demandé au secrétaire de
l'onu de remplir ses obligations en
matière de
[Musique]
de mise en oeuvre des accords qui ont
été conclus
et notamment que l'onu voit avec l'hôte
de cette rencontre en l'occurrence ce
sont les états unis donc les ici il ya
des infractions graves aux règles
diplomatiques qui ont été faites
notamment le siège de l'onu qui a la
propriété diplomatique
la généralité de l'onu a déjà dit que
ces restrictions n'étaient pas
normales et le secrétaire général de
l'onu doit agir sur le plan de
l'arbitrage ici pour résoudre ces
questions je lui rappelais d'ailleurs et
j'étais heureux que c'est son conseiller
juridique qui était présent lors de
notre entretien a entendu donc mes
arguments qui font qu'ils visent selon
lesquelles il faut régler cette question
de protocole
oui alors en ce qui concerne le
président baden a dit qu'il n'est que
les états unis n'emploierait plus la
force pour modifier les règles dans
d'autres pays d'abord il faut jamais
dire jamais on savait très bien
on dit que
regarder trump s'était retiré de
l'accord conclu sous ma propos de l'iran
donc aujourd'hui à des discussions pour
reprendre
la la mise en oeuvre de cet accord sur
le nucléaire iranien et
l'iran pose justement comme question aux
américains c'est à dire que si on
reprend ces discussions est ce que on
peut dire que la nouvelle administration
respectera ce que vous l'avenir et les
américains d on peut pas le faire parce
que il ya le droit international
mais il ya aussi les spécificités
interne et après ce qu'a dit le
président baden sur le fait d'imposer
par la force la démocratie
peut-être qu'ils vont essayer d'autres
moyens
pour modifier l'avis d'autres vies
donc
encourager une révolution n'est pas
forcément l'emploi de la force donc donc
regarder ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays on en libye en iran en
syrie et d'un autre sur notre voisin le
cren par conséquent nous voudrions
effectivement que les états unis passent
à l'étape suivante et qu'ils arrêtent
d'employer la force et d'une manière
générale qui cesse de s'occuper des
affaires des autres
nous avons des racines culturelles
civilisationnelles qui sont différentes
nous vivons sur la même planète nous
devons nous respecter les uns les autres
[Musique]
si vous avez des sources
demandez à ceux qui vous fournit ce
genre d'information nous nous avons
toute une série de contacts sur les
ministres au niveau des ministres des
affaires étrangères et du département
d'état
ce n'est pas la seule
voie de négociations il ya aussi
d'autres
mais quand les deux pays les deux
parties se mettront d'accord à ce moment
là un jour sera fixée et nous ferons une
déclaration en ce sens
oui c'est vrai vous avez raison je suis
presque enfants de vivre ici je fais
toujours qu'on parle de revoir ma
question
concerne
je sais p o
le secrétaire d'état blinken américain a
dit qu'il reste peu de temps les
ministres que ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'iran a dit hier qu'il
était prêt
à parer mans les états unis reçoivent
des messages différents pour vous étiez
mis d'accord sur
cet accord dites-nous qu'est ce qui va
arriver c'est les états unis ne revienne
pas dans le geste et hoa dans l'accord
de vienne est ce que l'iran va
promouvoir faut se lever lire on ne fait
rien
qui lui soit interdit dans la mesure où
ils respectent l'accord de non
prolifération
respecte le protocole complémentaires
sur les garanties
il ne respecte pas actuellement
certaines de ses obligations qui sont
propres justement à l'accord sur le
nucléaire
iranien qui n'est pas en exercice
actuellement puisque les américains s'en
sont retirés donc il s'agit de reprendre
l'intégralité de l'exécution de cet
accord et et à ce moment là les iraniens
n'auront plus de justification pour
trouver des exceptions à l'application
de cet accord
et
layar
par la personne de son directeur général
est en contact avec
l'iran il a un tableau précis de la
situation
et
le malien n'a pas de
raison de penser que l'accord qui avait
le rapport qui avait été signant en 2019
selon lequel
l'iran préparait des armes concrètes
évidemment nous voulons que les
discussions reprennent à 100% le plus
vite possible
mais premièrement le gouvernement
iranien vient seulement de se former et
je pense qu'il leur faudra une semaine
deux j'espère pas plus pour remettre en
place une nouvelle équipe de
négociations puisqu'il ya eu un jeu de
chaises musicales
et ensuite les états unis qu'en se sont
retirés de cet accord pendant plus d'un
an les iraniens ont continué à
mettre en oeuvre leurs obligations dans
la tente que les etats-unis se
ressaisissent ray et reviendrait donc
aujourd'hui évidemment on peut dire que
le temps est passé mais
oui c'est l administration précédente
américaine
aujourd'hui
et c'est l'héritage qui a reçu de
l'administration actuelle mais c'est
justement cette administration qui avait
été l'auteur de cet accord à l'origine
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler ici
sur toutes ces questions qui sont les à
cela vient thème qui est important ce
sont les sanctions que les états unis
ont imposé de façon illégale contre les
rangs pour de prétendues infraction à
cet acord mais ces sanctions elles
concernent pas seulement l'iran mais
aussi tous ceux
qui ont des échanges commerciaux
légitimes avec l'iran et notamment
ceux qui sont des fournisseurs
d'équipements militaires dont
l'interdiction a été fini donc ces
sanctions doivent être levés dans le
cadre de la reprise de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien et donc les
les échanges commerciaux ne doivent pas
être gêné par les sanctions américaines
nous avons entendu l'irak
ma question
à cause de la non reprise de l'accord
nous n'envisageons même pas ce genre de
scénario
nous avons un fort espoir
et je dois même un optimisme réfléchi
sur fait que nous trouverons un accord
et je pense que tous les pays et les
etats-unis l'iran doivent trouver un
intérêt dans la reprise de cet accord
la partie
[Musique]
avant le sommet
la situation s'est calmée encore une
question sur la syrie y at il un
consensus sur un accord entre la russie
et les etats-unis après la réunion à
genève
vice
ministre des affaires et monsieur bret
maire qui s'est tenue à genève
l'accord
sur l'est de l'ukraine entre mes
adjoints et
réunion à genève entre le ministre et
monsieur marc concernant l'est de
l'euphrate récemment
je suis pas informé de sa jeune n'avons
pas de canal des sifi qu'avec les états
unis pour discuter de l'ukraine
vous savez
la première question
je me suis mis à parler de l'ukraine
en ce qui concerne
le nord-ouest de la syrie nous employons
la force en fonction de la résolution 22
54 2 du conseil de sécurité de l'onu si
un site qui invite à lutter complètement
contre les groupes terroristes et il ya
eu un accord encore une fois je le
répète entre les présidents russe et
turc pour séparer les groupes
armée normaux des groupes terroristes
cela aurait dû être fait depuis
longtemps pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore arrivé donc un progrès lents mais
la menace du terrorisme
y ce qui est issu de ces bandits ne
cesse de se renouveler et dans la zone
de désescalade de d'élèves ces groupes
attaque les positions de l'armée
syrienne est
essayé plusieurs fois de lancer des
drones pour attaquer notre base de
mimine
et nos amis jure que le savent très bien
que nous n'allons pas nous résigner à
cette attitude est que nous l'allons
n'allons pas tolérer cette attitude de
la part des bandits
et notamment qui profite de la position
des militaires turcs sur place donc nous
allons parler en détail dans le cadre de
la préparation de la rencontre entre les
présidents turc et russe lui 29
septembre cette question sera une des
questions principales comment faire pour
que ce dont nous nous sommes nous sommes
convenus puisse être exécutée et que les
terroristes ne puissent pas diriger le
bal en ce qui concerne les contacts avec
les états unis sur
les questions de la rive droite de
l'euphrate oui nous avons des pistes des
échanges réguliers avec eux et nous
attirons leur attention sur leur
présence illégitime sur le territoire de
la syrie
sur le fait qu'ils occupent cette zone
sur la base notamment d'un staff et sur
la situation qui résulte de
de la question du camp de réfugiés de
robert
robban donc les discussions que nous
avons avec les américains au niveau
je me sers affaires étrangères et du
conseil de sécurité concernent
essentiellement le fait que les
américains oui se trouve sur place
de façon illégitime mais enfin c'est
quand même une réalité
il faut en tenir compte et
on va pas faire feu de toutes les armes
contre eux mais il ya quand même un
mécanisme de décomplexion qui fonctionne
et j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu' il fonctionne malgré
l'interdiction juridique qui avait été
prononcée par le congrès sur les
contacts au niveau des militaires
et le la direction de l'état major avait
indiqué justement que ce n'était pas
raisonnable
et qu'
il faut poursuivre ses contacts parce
que ils aident à la décomplexion en
syrie et ils permettent de traiter
normalement de la question de l'armement
s'il vous plaît
la turquie a exprimé ses préoccupations
concernant
le vote de la crise pendant les récentes
élections dans la douma d'état même si
la russie avait accordé une aide
humanitaire à la turquie
dans le contexte du coup vite et malgré
la coopération militaire pourquoi ça
c'est arrivé pourriez vous donner aux
commentaires sur les déséquilibres dans
ses relations et deuxième question
concerne le mali la france a exprimé ses
préoccupations concernant la présence
même des sous traitants russe militaire
au mali
maintenant d'autres
alliés régionaux se sont ont rejoint
cette préoccupation qui est la
proposition de la russie en ce qui
concerne la crimée la turquie n'était
pas la seule
à déclarer faire part de sa
préoccupation à propos de l'élection en
crimée mais encore une fois de
cette fumée qui était soulevée je dirais
que d'il ya cinq ans pour la précédente
élection de l'egypte la législature à la
douma il y avait eu aucune discussion
aucune déclaration à ce propos
en tout cas je n'ai pas le souvenir il
n'y a pas eu de choses le fait que cette
fois ci on se soit saisi de la question
de la crimée
avec la plate forme de crime et qui
s'est fait à qui est tout ce bruit
autour des élections je pense que c'est
une tentative de détourner l'attention
du fait que kiev
avec le président s'élève qu'à sa tête a
complètement échoué son
opération de pour surmonter le conflit
qui est dans le sud est du pays bien des
choses évidentes qui sont très clairs
avec ses lois qui interdisent
au sud-est de l'ukraine de se définir
son statut conformément aux accords de
minsk et il ya l'union européenne
approuvent que leurs clients puissent
rayer
les termes de l'accord de minsk donc
encore une fois c'est une occasion de
détourner l'attention et celle ci a très
bien compris qu'il fallait
détourner l'attention de son échec de
son sabotage
et donc on se sert de cette thématique
crimen la deuxième raison je pense que
c'est aussi un manque de
professionnalisme
diplomatique
un absence de diplomates isme parce que
ils comprennent très très bien que la
question de la crimée est terminée une
bonne fois pour toutes après vous avez
parlé du mal et oui j'ai entendu ces
questions
m'a posé ces questions par exemple
ministre aux affaires étrangères
français
le représentant de la politique
étrangère de l'union européenne la
question c'est que
dans ce pays aujourd'hui une transition
qui se fait
il y à des élections
pour que le peuple puisse on revient et
donc il va y avoir au mois de février
des élections qui vont sur sous l'égide
de l'union africaine et d'autres
organisations internationales
les pouvoirs les autorités de transition
continue d'ailleurs cette lutte contre
le terrorisme et dans cette optique qu
ils se sont adressés à des compagnies
armées privées
parce que la france a si j'ai bien
compris décidé de réduire
significativement sa présence militaire
qui
luttent contre les cellules terroristes
qui sont dans le nord du pays et qui
n'ont pas finalement pas réussi puisque
les risques continuent à mener le bal
sur place
donc les autorités maliennes estimé que
leurs forces étaient insuffisantes sans
aide extérieure
et comme l'aide de ceux qui aiment qui
s'était engagé à déraciner le
terrorisme donc bah du coup ils
s'adressent à des compagnies
militaires privées russes nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça et cela ne concerne
que le gouvernement légitime ce qui est
considéré comme
les forces de transition légitime et
ceux qui proposent ce genre de service
je
souligne d'ailleurs que
par la ligne 2
le l'état nous apportons une aide ceux
ne s'agit pas ici de compagnies privées
mais il s'agit ici de d'une aide
officielle nous avons un programme de
coopération
politique et militaire
et et nous
participons à la mise en place de
missions de maintien de la paix en
conformément avec les décisions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu encore une
fois
je veux pas qu'il y ait de doute là
dessus lemay des affaires étrangères
malien que j'ai vu hier a dit si ça pose
pas de problème
il ya d'autres tiens c'est une de nos
collègues de l'union européenne comme
l'a dit joseph bourrel
s'ils disent par exemple le disque
directement ne travaille pas en afrique
parce que c'est notre territoire
je pense que ce serait mieux de
coordonner nos mouvements entre la
fédération de russie et l'union
européenne en matière de lutte contre
autorise pas seulement au mali mais dans
toute la zone du seul mais dire que je
suis ici le premier et vous devez
quitter les lieux d'abord c'est
humiliant pour le gouvernement de bamako
qui a invité des partenaires étrangers
et deuxièmement c'est pas comme ça qu'on
doit par les
[Musique]
résultats
discutés
est encore un sujet
appelle
considérait l'accord entre les états
unis l'australie et la grande bretagne
cet accord correspond
aux accords de libération
cet accord et que pensez vous de ceux de
cette alliance tripartite qui a fait
autant de bruit et qui contredit les
accords partenaires dans le cadre de
l'otan
en ce qui concerne la question de
reconnaître ou reconnaître les élections
les recommandations de du parlement bain
nous n'avons pas entendu de
déclarations puisque le parlement
européen ce n'est pas ça qui
décide mais j'ai écouté josep borrell et
j'ai entendu notamment c'est sa
déclaration
et
notamment sur le fait que
le l'union européenne distingue les
autorités de moscou et le peuple et je
considérais que
ce n'est pas
c'est pas une bonne phrase je pense
qu'il l'a bien compris j'espère que ce
n'est qu'une phrase est pas là sans live
que les paroles dépassent la pensée mais
là donc ici il n'ya pas de
l'indication
quelqu'un qui pourrait refuser les
accords qui est les résultats des
élections qui ont été proclamés en ce
qui concerne
l'accord entre les états unis et la
grande bretagne et l'australie sur les
sous marins évidemment
cet événement
juste après la fuite de l'afghanistan
invite à se poser des questions sur ce
qui se passe au sein de l'alliance et je
comprends que il ya évidemment une
offense sur le plan commercial pour la
france mais ça veut dire est ce que ces
alliances sont fiables
est-ce que la l'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe est toujours d'actualité
évidemment pour
le le camp occidental c'est une question
grave qui se pose et qui doivent la
résoudre nous n'avons pas l'intention de
nous mêler de cette histoire mais les
conséquences de ce qui se passe
évidemment nous pouvons les ressentir et
cela peut influencer sur de relations
avec l'union européenne cela peut
susciter un intérêt dans l'union
européenne ce parce que là quand on voit
que pour la cobas ont certains utilisent
leur avantage
géopolitique dans un espace considérable
puisqu'on voit que le centre de la vie
politique se déplace vers
donc j'en ai parlé avec mes
interlocuteurs qui représente l'union
européenne et qui voit bien que cela et
cela se produit cela ne leur plaît pas
si on va nous
repousser exercer une dissuasion contre
nous
et alors j'ai demandé à bord elle dans
quoi ils veulent nous impliquer qui m'a
dit il faut aller vous quittiez le
malien voilà c'est ça c'est ça sa
politique et sur quoi repose sa
politique je le dis ouvertement
je pense pas enfreindre ici normes
éthiques partir je le dis publiquement
et je donne je ne fais que citer les
exemples qui représente cette politique
européenne ensuite concerne l'accord sur
la non prolifération des armes
nucléaires oui cette question a déjà été
abordé dans les couloirs à vienne parce
que
l'ajustement est responsable de cette de
ces questions et et elle doit assurer
le la limitation de l'armé nucléaire
donc
l'iran par exemple doit s'armer
doit enrichir son uranium à 99% voilà
bon il ya une expertise de la vie qu'il
doit se faire ici
après il était question de
sous marins nucléaires la question
s'était déjà posée il ya plusieurs
décennies
mais aujourd'hui
la situation dans la situation actuelle
s'il a eu dit que tout cela est conforme
aux règles en matière de sécurité que
il y aura pas de passage à l'armé
nucléaire à ce moment là il n'y aura pas
de problème
l'associated press
je représente
presse ça fait toujours plaisir de vous
voir ici
le secrétaire général antonio côté
publié
prévention la veille des groupes de haut
niveau
il a dit que le monde pourrait plonger
dans une autre guerre froide encore plus
dangereuse
si les états unis et la chine il
n'arriverait pas à corriger leurs
relations qui la traitent de
dysfonctionnelle
selon lui il faut éviter une nouvelle
guerre à tout prix telle guerre froide
sera différente de des guerres
précédentes entente entre les états unis
et l'union soviétique je cite elle sera
encore plus dangereuse et elle sera bien
plus difficile à gérer
comment la russie at-elle réagi à ces
propos as deux secrétaires généraux ne
pensez pas que nous n'avons pas été
attentif à cette question avec monsieur
good run nous avons bien évidemment
vu le ce regain de tensions notamment
entre la chine et les états unis et nous
voyons bien qu'ils
commandent y joue le premier violon
et dans cette évolution et bien sûr cela
nous préoccupe et toute confrontation ou
ne fait que gêner la vie normale de la
population sur notre planète que nous
avons en commun
notamment les stratégies de l'océan
pacifique ou l'amant est une de celles
des organisations étaient visait
justement à
restreindre à limiter la chine dans dans
ses eaux donc ça c'est une stratégie qui
c'est qui a été voulue ou par exemple
l'union convient d'évoquer australie
etats unis et grande bretagne ayant pour
but justement d'aider la de l'australie
a dissuadé
la chaîne et les pays qui représente
l'association
noeux
de la cern
ils sont été justement intéressé à
savoir comment vont les relations entre
la chine et l'asean donc évidemment
c'est pas une discussion très rapide
mais il ya un code de comportement
de conduite en mer de chine qui est
élaboré et je pense que c'est le moyen
le plus sûr d'assurer une navigation
maritime en toute sécurité
et en évitant toutes les provocations de
la part des pays occidentaux qui peuvent
créer des chefs des schémas géopolitique
antichan je considère que les relations
entre les grandes puissances doivent se
faire de façon équilibrée normal pour
éviter que ces relations ne dégénère en
guerre nucléaire évidemment je sais bien
que le président poutine des présidents
baden et répéter encore une fois quand
ils se sont vus à genève qu'il fallait
éviter une guerre nucléaire
mais en tout cas aucune guerre entre ces
grandes puissances nucléaires ne doit
être envisagée puisque évidemment parce
que les risques autour d'un tel qu'on
fixe ont un jeu sont importants il n'y a
rien de nouveau le mann heat et n'a rien
inventé de nouveaux simplement il ya des
discussions il faut discuter il faut
trouver
des compromis les
comme a dit le président biden je te dis
oh c'est important ce n'est pas
seulement dans les affaires mais aussi
dans la politique aussi réunir les
conditions normales pour une vie normale
et arrêter de montrer ses muscles pour
dire que je suis le plus important non
les grandes puissances doivent ressentir
notre responsabilité vis-à-vis des
peuples vis-à-vis de toute l'université
le président train avait proposé 1
le président poutine avait proposé un
sorte de g5 et des pays membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu et nous essayons de nous mettre
d'accord avec nos partenaires avec la
chesnaie et l'airé trois représentants
occidentaux
pour justement pour avoir une discussion
un format peut-être peut-être en
visioconférence au début mais en tout
cas c'est
un moyen important peut-être le seul
pour pouvoir discuter je pense que les
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité ici doivent nous montrer ici
leur volonté politique
concernant le retrait des forces
étrangères
officielle de combattre depuis la libye
je ya plusieurs écoles des portes
dépensé 70 ce qui devrait partir après
les élections
du gouvernement le nouveau audio
gouvernement devrait les demandes et
d'une manière officielle d'autres
considèrent qu'il devrait se retirer
avant les élections avant le 24 décembre
pour assurer la tenue
crédible des élections et des résultats
représentants officiels du concept de
presse présidentiel a déclaré
aujourd'hui que vous avez évoqué deux
points
dans votre réunion avec monsieur melfi
d'abord vous avez évoqué la nécessité de
réconciliation entre les partis
les biens et vous avez parlé des forces
la russie comment elle perçoit on
aperçoit telle
encore faut-il retirer les forces
étrangères avant les élections ou après
les élections
pour assurer la transparence c'est pas
fondamentaux retend avant les élections
après élections l'essentiel c'est que à
la conférence à la deuxième conférence
de berlin cette année il a été noté dans
le document final que tout
les groupes armés doivent quitter la
libye no
collègues turcs on apportait une
exception en disant que
le monsieur sahara que j'avais je
demander une aide mais l'autre partie de
la société libyenne s'étaient notamment
le parlement à tobrouk qui n'est pas
moins légitime que le gouvernement
ces deux organes ont été créées
conformément aux accords qui avaient été
conclus
avec l'armée nationale les mêmes
invités aussi des forces de l'étranger
et il paye pour ça
et donc cette situation et parallèlement
ce qu'on peut qualifier de mercenaires
sont moins de thé sont apparus certains
sont venus de syrie des deux côtés
d'ailleurs est du tchad et d'autres
d'autres d'autres pays africains donc
dès le début dès que la question a porté
sur ce problème nous avons dit que nous
étions pourvu que si cela se fasse ce
fait
compte tenu de
la présence militaire sur l'état venu de
l'étranger il faut faire en sorte que
tous partent en même temps de façon
synchronisée par étapes et de façon
synchronisée pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
déséquilibre or en libye depuis plus
d'un an le cessez-le-feu est respecté et
il ne faut pas créer 2 tentation
l'éventualité de l' usage de la force
militaire
est ce que voulait favoriser pour
trouver sur un plan de retrait
ils doivent le faire dans leurs comités
5 + 5 nous sommes prêts à aider mais si
il continue à travailler sur des choses
qui ne sont pas prioritaires
je pense qu on n'avancera pas il y aura
jamais d'élection à ce moment là le 24
décembre ils viennent d'adopter
une base législative
pour les élections et ensuite le
parlement à noter à voter sur la
légitimité du gouvernement
or ce qu'il faut ici c'est que il ya une
discussion sérieuse sur la façon de
vivre ensuite
donc les
discussions sur la participation de nos
participations
il semble vouloir y participer
ici nos collègues au secrétariat
commencent eux à créer des difficultés
artificielle sur une présence de l'onu
en lui aujourd'hui il faut se concentrer
sur le respect de la corde de la nana
l'année dernière on pensait pas qu'il y
aurait un accord aujourd'hui or cet
accord existe donc maintenant il ne faut
pas chercher à tirer la couverture à soi
d'un centre ans au soudan ou dans
l'autre et promouvoir un agenda secret
merci nous sommes très content de vous
revoir encore une fois dans le cadre de
cette conférence de presse quelle est
votre position dans le cadre de
négociations concernant
le traité sur l'utilisation des armes
nucléaires sur le lancement des
missiles de la corée premièrement
rencontre concernant votre deuxième
question j'ai entendu que des signaux
venait de pyongyang
pour une normalisation des accords entre
les deux république de corée nous avons
toujours été pour le soutien cette
discussion
l'administration présentant tu ne sais
pas toujours
prononcée clairement là dessus puisque
elle cherchait à maîtriser ce processus
il faudrait avoir une
une volonté plus constructive sur les
discussions entre les deux corées bien
entendu le les lancements domicile ne
facilite pas les choses mais en tout cas
cette fois-ci séoul quand c'est arrivé
on cherchait à ne pas dramatiser la
situation et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose dès qu'on commence à
recourir aux critiques publiques aux
condamnations évidemment ça réduit
fortement
les simulations pour un discours apaisé
pour un dialogue apaisé
et constructif donc je pense qu'il faut
des discussions de confiance et non pas
des accusations
mutuelles au micro en ce qui concerne
nos discussions avec les américains sur
la stabilité stratégique il ya eu au
mois de juillet un premier round de
négociations est la deuxième étape doit
se faire la semaine prochaine
merci ma question suivante
à
[Musique]
renoncer à notre
en prison les presses ont publié
plusieurs fois des informations
la possibilité de les échanger contre
les américains
de changer réaliste
j'ai du mal à me faire des pronostics de
la part d un maintien mais nous avons à
de nombreuses reprises tenté de résoudre
le sort de nos concitoyens notamment
faisant fonctionner la convention du
conseil de l'europe sur
l'extradition le transfert des
prisonniers pour l'exécution de leur
peine et c'est une convention du conseil
de l'europe et les américains ne veulent
absolument pas entendre cet argument et
il disait que ces citoyens
étaient des
jeunes disent que c'était une ruse est
ici qui avait une ruse notamment en
thaïlande et que la procédure n'avait
pas été respectée et il
y avait aussi le liberia aussi qui est
impliqué dans cette histoire donc alors
qu'on a vu des arrestations savait-elle
caution aux seychelles ou un nos
concitoyens avaient été enlevés et est
placé dans un agent donc ici il ya des
attaques provoqué qui sont faites contre
nos concitoyens pour obtenir je sais pas
quoi peut-être je sais pas peut-être
pour les obliger à coopérer en tout cas
c'est inacceptable en ce qui concerne
les échanges nous avons depuis longtemps
on dit les présidents du poutine et
baden parmi d'autres thèmes ont abordé
ces questions ils ont dit que les
services de sécurité correspondant
qui s'occupe de ses affaires chez nous
comme chez eux à washington vont
poursuivre leurs discussions
pour valider des solutions acceptables
pour l'instant nous n'avons encore
trouvé aucune solution les américains ne
veulent qu'une chose c'est récupérer
l'or
concitoyens et ne sont pas très intacte
attentif vis-à-vis de nos demandes ils
sont intéressés par paul louis lannes
qui est condamnée pour espionnage des
arrêtés en flagrant délit et donc ça
peut absolument pas être content
comparer et
avec les motifs pour lesquels yaroshenko
et boudent sont emprisonnés pour 20 ans
il ya aussi d'autres citoyens américains
qui curieusement n'intéresse pas
beaucoup l'administration américaine
mais c'est mieux de parler que de rien
faire
déjà
les blés non vous écoute
vous oubliez votre question est donc
vous regardez dans votre ordinateur aïe
aïe aïe
concernant à l'accord de vienne
sur le programme nucléaire iranien
je sais que le conseil de sécurité
a eu à l'accord
[Musique]
même
apparemmment
le personnel je manie terre de l'onu en
ce qui concerne l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
nous parlons uniquement d'une reprise
totale
de la mise en oeuvre de l'accord sans
aucun ajout sans aucune condition
supplémentaire
les tentatives
d'ajouter des conditions sous forme
d'exigences en matière notamment
incluant par exemple programme de
missiles de l'iran où l'attitude de
l'iran dans la gens n'ont aucune
perspective
il faut pas confondre les pommes et les
oranges il faut
travailler sur l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ici à des préoccupations
sur la tête de telle ou telle personne
je vous assure qu'à ce moment là c'est
pas seulement les partenaires
délirant qui sont pros tuer mais l'iran
lui-même aussi comme n'importe quel pays
dans
le monde
le le golfe persique a
une histoire particulièrement complexe
il faut prendre en compte tout cela à
cet égard nous avons rappelé qu' il y a
un certain nombre d'années la russie
avait élaboré un système de sécurité
dans le golfe qui proposait justement un
dialogue ou quelque chose de similaire
sortes de discussions sur la sécurité
qui a en europe est bien de faire la
même chose
en toute transparence
s'inviter à des exercices militaires et
travailler sur des projets tout à fait
positif
donc il ya eu des discussions politiques
là dessus avec la participation des
scientifiques de tous les pays de la
région plus d'autres pays et en août de
cette année compte tenu de ces décisions
nous avons rappelé notre offre notre
proposition est un document a été édité
par l'assemblée générale et le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu il nous semble que
dans le
cadre de ce type de forums et j'espère
que nous allons pouvoir le créer il faut
discuter et les préoccupations
sur l'apparition de missiles dans la
région
parce qu'il n'existe pas seulement un
livre on a eu aussi à d'autres pays et
sur le fait de l'attitude de tel ou tel
pays et d'ailleurs le conflit du yémen
montre très bien que tant les intérêts
de l'arabie qui est d'autres pays arabes
que ceux de l'iran doivent être prises
en compte et je pense qu'un tel forum
serait plus étendue que simplement les
pays qui sont sur les bords du sur le
littoral du golfe mais je pensais à
d'autres pays comme la jordanie par
exemple comme
participant de la mise en place d'une
plateforme de discussions positives bien
entendu il faut que la ligue des pays
arabes
là les
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
l'union européenne et je pense que c'est
une approche tout à fait réaliste est
possible qu'ils peuvent faire et hier
nous avons eu des discussions avec des
ministres
des pays arabes du golfe et nous avons
des discussions là-dessus nous sommes
mis d'accord sur le fait que dans la
reprise de ces échanges ministériels
nous pourrions travailler là dessus en
ce qui concerne l'aide humanitaire à la
syrie vous savez que
j'en ai beaucoup parlé en détail hier
avec le secrétaire général de l'onu
ne pouvons pas être satisfaits de la
situation dans laquelle
on voit d infraction
très grave avec l'application de double
standard deux poids deux mesures par
exemple les réfugiés qui sont 6 millions
au liban turquie ans jordan et qui en
novembre de l'année dernière avec notre
aide damas avait organisé une conférence
sur les réfugiés justement pour mettre
en place des cons des conditions
favorables à leur retour
puisque je pense que la majorité d'entre
eux veulent revenir ce qui nous a
frappés c'est que les états unis
premièrement ont tout fait pour
menacés intimidés
ce qui devait participer à cette
conférence à damas et ce qui nous a
frappés c'est que l'organisation des
nations unies n'a pas participé à cette
conférence et il y avait simplement son
représentant à damas qui était là en
tant qu'observateur mais à l'époque
j'avais écrit à antonio terheege pour
dire que c'était
c'était
la non application de la résolution 22
54 du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
faisait qu il fallait encourager autant
que possible
faciliter
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire de
façon à faciliter le retour des réfugiés
au début de cette année l'union
européenne a organisé à bruxelles une
conférence qui je crois est annuel sur
les réfugiés
et il n'était pas prévu la participation
de la république arabe de syrie
alors que le coprésident était le
secrétaire général de l'onu
non seulement la syrie n'était pas
invité mais
et l'argent qui était collecté n'était
pas fait pour améliorer les
infrastructures
ensuite mais simplement pour payer le
séjour des réfugiés en turquie liban et
jordanie pour éviter qu'il retournerait
donc c'est vraiment se moquer
ouvertement du droit international des
droits de l'homme internationales donc
je demande à nos amis et aux médias qui
sont préoccupés par la
position d
plaçant d'ordinaire dans les zones de
conflits justement et réfléchissez à ça
il faut trouver une solution de
compromis et au mois de juillet nous
avons organisé jeu
un mécanisme
transfrontières de pour l'acheminement 2
de l'aide humanitaire essentiellement en
provenance de la turquie mais les pays
occidentaux
tiennent fermement à ce système et nous
avons de bonnes raisons de croire que
ici
il y à un ordre du jour qui est secret
ici et les informations sur le fait de
ceux qui
sur les camions qui se rendent là bas on
append n'avons pas beaucoup
d'informations et théoriquement il
faudrait vérifier chacun chaque camion
mais ce n'est physiquement pas possible
donc il faudrait pas que dans ces aides
il y est on sait pas ce qu'il ya ait
commencé répartis au sein de la zone
d'idleb est-ce que c'est pas utilisés
par les groupes terroristes
rebbah chan par exemple et les autres
structures similaires donc encore une
fois
si des mesures concrètes ne sont pas
prises pour débloquer le processus
d'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire par
damas comme ces exils exigé par le droit
ayman été un temps salle à ce moment là
nous allons fermer donc bloquer ces
acheminements louche regardez depuis
l'adoption de la résolution qui imposait
cet acheminement via d'un masque il ya
un convoi qui est passé mais pas entier
seulement la moitié du chargement qui a
été attendu à peu près un an
et qui n'a pas été qui n'a pas pu être
acheminés jusqu'au bout
l'orece a été bloquée et les convois
du comité intentions de la croix rouge
et
du croissant rouge
qui avait été préparé en avril 2020 ne
bouge pas donc ceux qui se préoccupent
de ceux qui ont faim devrait peut-être
s'intéresser à cela et
titiller les pays occidentaux pour
qu'ils réagissent et puis aussi l'onu
qui est obligé de
d'exécuter cette résolution
les aspects humanitaires
les itinéraires aussi même qu'ils sont
définis mais il est aussi la nécessité
des projets de restauration comme ils
s'appellent des infrastructures qu'il
s'agisse de l'alimentation en eau des
établissements de santé des
établissements scolaires et c est ça le
et le secrétariat de l'onu le sait
et la situation est complexe aujourd'hui
disons que depuis le début de cette
crise syrienne le secrétariat est
extrêmement passif en matière de
favorisation du retour des
des réfugiés en syrie il ya des
résolutions il faut les appliquer
merci monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
sa question porte sur palestine
le président abbas à dire que s'il sera
elle n'arrêtait pas l'occupation d'ici
un an les palestiniens
arrêteront de reconnaître l'état
d'israël ce qui
sera le début du chaos dans le moyen
haut rien la fédération de russie en
tant qu ami des palestiniens et pays qui
a de bonnes relations avec israël que
peut-elle faire pour ne pas laisser se
produire
ce qui vient d'être dit les palestiens
ont-ils le droit à la défense de m
en ce qui concerne le problème
israélo-palestinien oui c'est un
problème grave et
les
agitations qu'on voit au niveau de
l'administration américaine avec les
reconnaissances
2d du plateau du golan
et d annexion dans le cadre
du quasi état palestien ne n'arrange pas
la situation
et l'administration baden a prononcé son
attachement au à la solution des deux
états mais le premier ministre israélien
ne valide pas alors qu'un certain nombre
de responsables politiques israéliens ou
notre position en matière de
sécurité en israël
pour ne pas vivre en état de tension
permanente
au lieu de frapper les cibles qui
pourrait elle-même frapper israël mais
cherchait à favoriser une coexistence
des baies et
c'est d'ailleurs la modalité de
résolution qui avait approuvé par le
conseil de sécurité nous de notre côté
nous sommes convaincus que le les
dirigeants israéliens
on des discussions aujourd'hui qui
principalement se limite simplement à la
question de la sécurité dans les
territoires palestiniens et je considère
que ce serait une erreur
de
qu'il s'agisse des processus de
règlement au moyen-orient avec la libye
la syrie deux états si on oublie la
question israélo palestinien c'est c'est
mauvais c'est le conflit le plus ancien
que nous ayons ici qui a été souvent
[Musique]
qui avait souvent fait l'objet de
tentatives de résolution mais la
solution de deux états ne réussit
toujours pas alors que c'est
probablement la plus cohérente et il
m'avait paru très cohérent il ya vingt
ans de voir la solution
de la ligue arabe à l'initiative du roi
d'arabie qui avait dit que dès que
l'état palestinien sera aidé qui
correspond à tous les critères définis
par l'onu à ce moment là les pays arabes
arrangerait leurs relations avec eux
l'israël ça me paraissait tout à fait
raisonnable et l'administration trump a
essayé de placer les choses complètement
de façon complètement inversé et
la corde avram qui était proposée par
des pays arabes ces parts est justement
de cette logique c'est à dire d'abord
normaliser les relations entre israël et
les arabes et après on réfléchira que
faire avec la police et nous évidemment
nous allons toute normalisation
quelles que soient les états confirment
que je concerné mais encore une fois on
suit concerne les palestiniens je
considère que les accords et désaccords
de parennes des émirats
avec le soudan avec le maroc cela
il
ils doivent correspondre aux décisions
de l'onu sur cette question et il faut
continuer à respecter ce principe
et le calcaire on vous dit que ils ont
le droit de lutte évidemment ils vont
demander l'avis de personne
et le règlement de la question
palestinienne
constitue un facteur important qui fait
que le peuple arabe palestinien dans la
rue donc on voit des
prédicateurs qui est d'isola on nous
avait prévenus on nous avait promis un
état où et on voit que les jeunes qui ne
sont pas forcément qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément été scolarisés sont très
sensibles à 7
rhétorique et quand on parle de
l'affluence de ce conflit sur la
stabilité de l'ensemble de la région et
quand on en parle de ça vaut aux
collègues israéliens non non c'est pas
du tout ça le problème n'est pas si
important
c'est une approche à courte vue et alors
justement nous nous avons soutenu
l'initiative du président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas mais nous
lui avons dit qu'il faut bien préparer
cette conférence qui le réclame de ses
voeux et nous voudrions absolument
faire renaître le prétoire de discussion
et inclure dans ce travail les pays
arabes
par exemple les quatre pays arabes qui
ont des liens avec israël
l'egypte la jordanie
les émirats et bas-rhin et peut-être
aussi
l'arabie saoudite comme auteurs de
l'initiative arabe donc quatre plus un
plus de plus tout cela avec eux donc
israël et la palestine donc si certains
considère que ces
troubles
prématurée nous proposons peut-être 7/10
plus cette discussion peut se faire chez
nous ou ailleurs en tout cas il faut pas
perdre de temps il faut inventer nous
allons faire le maximum pour que cette
approche soit premier je voulais dire
aussi autre chose à ce propos oui ce qui
est le plus important si tout ce que
nous avons dit avec vous dépend de
beaucoup de facteurs
et mais il ya d'autres choses qui ça
peut dépendre d'israël ou d'autres
structures régionales mais en tout cas
il ya une question qui ne dépende de
rien si ce n'est des palestine m c'est
l'unité palestinienne
les tentatives de la restaurer cette
unité palestinienne il ya deux ans s'il
y avait eu des discussions où il y avait
des élections or rien ne s'est fait
et ce manque justement de compréhension
entre ramallah et gaza
évidemment ça c'est très négatif si les
palestiniens
restaurer leur unité entre eux ce serait
beaucoup plus simple pour eux est
beaucoup plus efficace pour eux pour
discuter avec israël malades vous savez
que le premier ministre israélien
netanyahou à l'époque il avait dit lui
même comment je peux avoir des
discussions quand je sais pas avec qui
parle me parler parce que abbas et
seulement ramallah et les autres je sais
pas
donc évidemment ça c'est une influence
considérable sur la volonté d'avoir des
résultats politiques globo
nous aidons enfin nous n'est donc pas
puisque pour l'instant c'est difficile
mais en tout cas nous nous encourageons
et nous travaillons avec toutes les
parties
palestiniennes ils ont été invités
souvent à moscou tous il survenu
il ya des discussions ils disent oui il
faut que nous nous unissions mais
ensuite
ça marche pas
première question
la commission européenne a accusé cette
semaine la russie d'être
source des attaques
pourriez vous répondre à ces accusations
vous avez
laquelle
les résultats des élections allemandes
et deuxième question
[Musique]
reid considère qu'il est accusé d'une
manière injuste
à propos de trésorerie de jeudi à propos
de monsieur paul biya et de monsieur
reid l'un est arrêté willan pour
espionnage il était en flagrant délit et
l'autre
parce qu'il a attaqué et frappé à
plusieurs reprises un policier
vous savez vous états unis combien on
donne d'années de prison pour
l'application pour l' usage de la force
contre un policier à mon avis avec
beaucoup donc ce en répondant à des
questions principe quand je dis que boot
et l'autre citoyens russes avaient été
enlevés et placés dans des agents
ensuite on leur a collé une affaire de
narcotiques et de trafic d'armes avec
plus de vingt ans de prison alors qu'il
n'avait jamais frappé il avait aucune
intention de
d'entrée en infraction avec les règles
mondiales donc encore une fois ici il
faut être cohérent nos collègues
américains ils peuvent se vexer si
quelqu'un est arrêté mais enfin il faut
appliquer les mêmes standards
et en cas d'attaqué contre un policier
puis regarder si si la même source par
exemple savez ce qui s'est passé au
capitole un don votre première question
c'était
oui nous sommes tout à fait prêts à
étudier tous les faits or on ne nous
fournit aucun fait ce ne sont que des
déclarations
orales en 2007 on nous avait à côté
d'avoir accusé d'avoir empoisonné les
tuniques au polonium en nous fournir
aucune preuve
le procès fait à deux
huit lots sans examen des dossiers et on
veut faire la même chose avec le
processus le procès sur cette femme qui
est décédée à soc berrer dans le
contexte de la sphère dit je ne crie pas
là et on veut utiliser la mort de cette
femme pour faire une enquête secrète
et on ne présente aucun fait et pour les
skripal c'est la même chose
pareille avec le
bruit ni malaise de malaisie alan c'est
pareil le procès à la haye a établi
qu'il avait des raisons de croire que
les états-unis suppose qu'ils ont des
des images satellites prouvant que c'est
la russie on n'a jamais vu ces images eu
ce coup tu niques et le tribunal à l'ail
de l' ai dit voilà si les américains le
disent on les croit c'est comme
schwarzenegger qui disaient
ouais faites moi confiance oim
mais monsieur reagan ajoute
mais vérifier qu'on fait confiance mais
vérifier et ben voila nous à propos du
boeing de la maladresse nous avons donné
les enregistrements radars beaucoup
dément les ukrainiens ne donne aucune
information radars
et il les avait eu au moment dé il y
avait les enregistrements des
discussions
entre les aiguilleurs du ciel et les
pilotes
donc on nous accuse de tours nous accuse
de voir pratiquer l'ingérence dans les
élections à mike
et nous avons discuté avec nos
homologues notamment avec rex tillerson
et on nous avait dit que nous avons des
preuves de l'implication des des âmes et
des russes dans l'élection la maca
si vous avez des preuves vous pouvez
nous les montrer
demandez à vos services secrets ils
comprendront de quoi il s'agit voilà
toute la discussion c'est ça vous
trouvez ça normal
pareil avec les les
les cyber attaques
le président biden à genève quand il a
rencontré
le président poutine a dit que les
les hackers avaient les pirates
informatiques avaient attaqué une
fabrique de viande avait attaqué un
réseau de distribution de gaz
j'avais dit c'est peut-être pas votre
gouvernement mais ce sont des gens du
territoire de la russie nous avons
attiré l'attention sur le fait que cette
dernière année
nous avons le plus grand nombre
d'attaqués informatiques sur nos
ressources venez pro
justement des états unis plus de la
moitié en partie aussi de l'allemagne et
d'autres pays
et quarante cinq fois nous avons adressé
des demandes concrètes avec des faits
stipulé pour justifier nous avons envoyé
ça nous en avons reçu nous avons reçu
que 19
nous avons
reçu dix demandes et nous avons répondu
à chacun à chacune d'entre elles et
quand les deux présidents poutine et
baden en ont parlé à genève les
américains se sont mis d'accord pour
passer à un travail systématique
avec des canaux spéciaux de
communication qui travaille sur les
attaques informatiques et nous avons
aujourd'hui l'espoir que les choses
avancent un peu
hâlé sélection en allemagne bonne chance
à tous
deux dernières questions
monsieur lavrov la semaine dernière ont
été publiés les résultats préliminaires
de l'enquêté américaine
du procureur de rennes qui s'occupait de
la rémission de 10 rachel gates il
dévoile l un des initiateurs d'une des
personnes qui étaient à l'origine de
cette affaire ce n'est pas pour la
première fois que les personnes les
responsables officiels elle dénonce les
accusations qui était un
fait contre la russie ce paradoxe
avec le fait dans le fait que les
sanctions restent alors qu'il y à des
dénonciations quelle est la position
russe ce sujet vous savez en fait vous
avez de la réponse ou même
[Musique]
cessé peu approprié ce genre de choses
ce genre de déclaration fait sans
réflexion sans analyse alors il faut
analyser la situation
éviter de s'abîmer les relations des
deux côtés
c'est une tradition américaine de cette
façon nous n'allons pas lever les
sanctions ou jamais
par exemple le cren ne cesse de demander
des sanctions sans rien
apparemment comprendre ce qui se passe
mais nous nous allons pas fait jouer ce
jeu là nous n'avons pas d'autres
partenaires effectivement mais petit à
petit je ne veux pas être pessimiste
sur certaines
orientations
stabilité stratégique en en piraterie
informatique
nous espérons quand même que sur
certains points
les communications
intergouvernementale vont permettre
quand même de suivre un cours
mutuellement respectueuses la dernière
question
merci
[Musique]
ma question
concerne la palestine pour tous les
passionnés a été déjà été dit
beaucoup disent que
des
les localités pour les palestiniens cela
exige beaucoup de moyens est ce que la
communauté internationale
devrait
trouver une solution égal pour tout le
monde deuxième question porte sur le
yémen et la situation humanitaire
se beazley a dit il ya deux jours
au moins cinquante mille 50 mille îles
minit
souffrent de faim des milliers de
yéménites
ont besoin dead ont besoin
d'alimentation et souffre de femmes de
famine pensez vous que la communauté
internationale
et la russie en tant que parti à ne plus
rien faire pour le peuple yéménite
parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait assez de
pression sur l'egypte peut pas dire que
la communauté internationale ne fait pas
assez d'efforts pour convaincre les
parties de ce conflit
à s'asseoir à la table des
discussions
pas seulement pour échanger mais aussi
pour trouver un compromis il ya un
certain nombre de facteurs ici qui à mon
grand regret qui subjectivement et qui
sont les rôles à la volonté de certaines
personnes de se maintenir longtemps au
pouvoir qui
font obstacle à
aux discussions et à la possibilité de
trouver un compromis je vais pas entrer
dans les détails mais le fait que le
yémen est un pays où est survenu une des
plus grandes catastrophes humanitaires
au monde ça a été dit déjà il y a
beaucoup de temps alors que le conflit
ne faisait que commencer qu'on était en
pleine période chaude par
l'intermédiaire de nos
notre représentation diplomatique
l'ambassadeur qui est à ryad donc
l'ambassadeur
soutien l'envoyé du
secrétaire général de l'onu
et
aujourd'hui on a on est dans un
cul de sac
et il faut que tout le monde ait bien
conscience de la situation en ce qui
concerne les
localités
les colonisations qui ont été faites
encore une fois cela ne crée de fait que
créer des faits sur le terrain qui
empêche la création de la formation de
l'état palestinien
donc il y aurait par exemple l'idée de
créer un état où tout le monde se régale
mais je considère qu'elle n'est pas
réaliste beaucoup considèrent que
considère que si c'est cela le
caractères
hébraïques deux
juifs de l'état disparaît et puis il ya
ceux qui peuplent d'israël et les
scientifiques disent que
on risque de voir l'apparition d'un
apartheid et je suis convaincu que la
solution à deux états est la seule voie
est beaucoup dans l'élite politique sont
bien d'accord et ksar et qu' ils
considèrent eux-mêmes qu'il faut
travailler à cela
merci au revoir